WHEREVER WHAT DO WHATEVER THEY
DARN ARE PLEASE.
THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
JOINING ME IS STEVE MALOY.
STEVE, REACT TO THE "ANGLE."
THEY WRAP THIS UP IN THIS
LAUDABLE GOAL OF REDUCING
TRAFFIC FATALITIES WHICH
EVERYONE WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
BUT THEY USE THAT STATISTIC FROM
2021 COMPARING TO 2020 WHEN HE
HAD MAJOR LOCKDOWNS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
HOW VALID IS THAT?
>> WELL, YOU DID A GREAT JOB IN
THE "ANGLE."
YOU TIED IT ALL TOGETHER
BEAUTIFULLY.
THEY HATED THE CAR FAY LONG
TIME.
I WROTE ABOUT THIS 13 YEARS AGO
IN MY BOOK GREEN HELL.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET US OUT OF
CARS.
NOW THEY WILL TRY TRAFFIC
FATALITIES.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THEIR USE OF STATISTICS IS
DISHONEST.
THAT'S NOTHING NEW.
PEOPLE WILL BE SURPRISED WHEN
THAT GO DOWNTOWN TO WORK.
IT'S MORE INCONVENIENT FOR CARS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
DRIVE YOUR CAR AND PARK YOUR
CAR.
SPEED LIMITS HAVE BEEN REDUCED
AND PARKING AREAS HAVE BEEN
REDUCED.
GASOLINE PRICES ARE UP.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOING
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO DRIVE.
WHY?
THEY DON'T LIKE CARS.
THEY DON'T LIKE WHAT CARS ENABLE
WHICH IS LIVING IN THE SUBURBS.
>> Laura: ISN'T THIS PARTLY
A CONTROL THING AS IT WAS WITH
COVID-19?
THEY DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE VIRUS
WHEN MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WERE
CROSSING THE BORDER WITHOUT
BEING TESTING.
THAT WAS A JOKE FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THE SAME WITH THIS, CORRECT?
YOU CAN'T JUST JUMP IN AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE RIGHT NOW AND
TRAVEL 500 MILES QUICKLY?
>> YES, THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE GAVE AMERICANS AND THE
WORLD MORE FREEDOM.
NOW THE GOVERNMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE, THEY
WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO WORK ON
KILL SWITCHES TO TURN YOUR CAR
OFF WHEN THEY WANT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT CONTROL AS IT
EVERYTHING ENVIRONMENTAL.
I HAVE WORKED ON ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES FOR 30 YEARS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S ABOUT CONTROLLING WHAT
PEOPLE DO.
>> Laura: HERE'S JEN PSAKI ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF DITCHING THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
>> OVER THE COURSE OF DECADES WE
ARE A CLEAN ENERGY SUPER POWER
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT JUST WHERE
THE JOBS ARE BUT WHERE THE
ADVANTAGE WILL LIE IN 30 YEARS.
>> Laura: THE WHITE HOUSE THINKS
NOBODY WILL BE USING OIL IN THE
NEXT 10 YEARS.
CHINA WILL BE USING OIL.
>> CHINA WILL USE OIL TO MAKE
ALL OF THE GREEN TECH STUFF WE
ARE FORCED TO BUY IN AMERICA.
WE SHOULD BE THE OIL AND GAS AND
COAL SUPER POWER.
WE HAVE ALL OF THE ENERGY BUT
THEY WANT US DEPENDENT ON CHINA.
THE MORE THE GREEN AGENDA
PASSES, IT MAKES US MORE
DEPENDENT ON COMMUNIST CHINA.
ALL OF THE MATERIALS FOR GREEN
TECH COMES FROM CHINA.
NONE OF THESE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN PASSED EVEN BOTHER TO
IMAGINE THAT THESE MATERIALS
SHOULD COME FROM AMERICA AND NOT
COMMUNIST CHINA.
OTHERWISE, WE ARE DEPENDENT ON
CHINA.
>> Laura: THEY ARE FINE WITH
THAT.
THIS WAS ALL IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" TODAY.
WANTING AMERICANS TO DITCH BEEF
FOR A CERTAIN INSECT.
WATCH.
>> UNLESS WE MAKE MAJOR
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE FOOD WE EAT,
WE ARE COOKED.
ONE OF THOSE DIETARY CHANGES
MIGHT MAKE YOU SQUEAMISH.
>> WE WILL FINISH OFF WITH
GRASSHOPPERS.
>> YES, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
INSECTS, SPECIFICALLY EATING
THEM.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Laura: THEY ARE LIKE HANDING
THE ELECTION TO THE REPUBLICANS.
JUST RUN THAT FOR THE NEXT 3
YEARS AND SAY DO YOU WANT BACON
BIT ON THAT ON YOUR SALAD?
>> THE "NEW YORK POST" AND
OTHERS WANTED PEOPLE TO E